does anyone else find it odd that they
don't teach about the world's first
human civilization in school the
creators of so many things that we
utilize all the time in our daily lives
more than 6,000 years later including
well the modern calendar that's right
the calendar based off of the lunar
cycles originates from the Sumerians
most people are not aware of this
in fact when I say that they're the
creators of things we utilize all the
time in our daily lives while including
time itself the 6012 based counting
system that's used for measuring hours
minutes and seconds which is also
utilized in basic mathematics and
geometry for measuring degrees and
angles minutes and seconds in fact the
Sumerians are the creators of the very
first writing system all together also
referred to as Kanaya form which was an
advanced system that even utilized
pictographs just as we used today
symbols to represent entire sentences in
this video I'm gonna share with you many
things that the Sumerians created in
fact even stories that originate from
the most common religions on earth go
great back to the Sumerians and most
people have no idea but for some reason
they're not even required testing or
even learning by the Department of
Education in fact if you go to any
history textbook through high school
you'll find only one to three sentences
total about the Sumerians which are
usually included in other paragraphs on
other topics such as the fact that they
are the creators of the wheel but it's
the things that they somehow knew about
that we can't explain that our total
mysteries that I'll also discuss in this
video but if you're not familiar with
the ancient Sumerians they come from the
cradle of civilization Mesopotamia the
Fertile Crescent itself and we weren't
even aware of the Sumerians altogether
until more than 150 years ago upon the
discovery of a massive cachet of clay
and stone tablets in modern-day Iraq and
real quick you can see here the utilized
cylinder seals to create these tablets
but at the ancient library of
Ashurbanipal in modern-day Missoula Iraq
they found more than 30,000 of these
tablets many of which were broken and
this is also the same location where
they found these infamous wing bowls
some refer to them as the Anunnaki or
the sky gods and there's so much
speculation and debate about these but
this just happens to be the same site
the
I was at by some incredible
synchronicity during my deployment to
Iraq in 2009 and 2010 and by the way I
still need to make a video about my Iraq
experience a lot of people have asked
for that and explained how I went from
brainwash people who bought the lies to
thinking for myself and my journey to
awakening as I call it and I have a lot
to say about it because that war was a
massive scam lay money generating fraud
scam and an incredible crime against
humanity so look forward to that video
in the future but in these clay tablets
we've learned so many different things
that they had created not just glass or
the wheel as I mentioned earlier but
even the sailboat they even set the
platform for modern agriculture through
the invention of the plow and even the
seed sowing machine in fact the
Sumerians created the first sewer
systems canals and irrigation systems
and they even mapped it out here this is
a plaque showing advanced sewer systems
and water channels for agriculture and
speaking of maps they created those all
together and they utilized them to
create advanced trade routes and they
did this more than 3000 years prior to
the Silk Road the infamous Silk Road
which of course they do teach in school
and they traveled more than 3000
kilometers or nearly 1,900 miles all the
way over to Pakistan and what these
trade systems it created an explosion of
culture the Sumerians themselves are the
very first to utilize jewelry make up
and get this even beer these stone and
clay tablets annotate more than 500
different recipes for beer that's right
craft beer comes from the Sumerians
another interesting fact is that they
created instruments this stone tablet
describes 23 different instruments which
include various types of flutes drums
tambourines and even the harp you could
even jokingly argue that they are the
creators of entertainment itself I mean
look at this these tablets here they are
the first known conductors of wrestling
or mixed martial arts altogether at
least that's been annotated so what did
they do with all this the music the
booze the makeup the jewelry the beer
well look at this tablet right here yeah
yeah okay yeah you get what's going on
there and that's what almost 4,000 years
ago drinking beer and engaging in other
forms of entertainment altogether now
like I mentioned earlier the Sumerians
created the first writing system as well
as the first schools
and privileged individuals went there
and learned how to scribe themselves and
they just jumped right into it in fact
are the creators of the very first
contract altogether how hilarious is
that they didn't miss a beat with their
trading systems and then they guess what
this says pay up or else but where this
gets really interesting is that in these
stone and clay tablets they give credit
to all their knowledge not to any king
or inventor but they say that all the
knowledge was given to them by other
beings the Anunnaki which means from
heaven to earth came and many people
when they look at these various tablets
they speculate that this is where the
ancient astronaut hypothesis came from
and maybe you're familiar with zecharia
sitchin now this is a subject I have to
make a video on altogether about the
Anunnaki my thoughts and zecharia
sitchin and everything I've looked into
this quite a bit I know that there's a
lot of speculation out there and I don't
agree with everything that people have
stated about these ancient astronaut
hypothesis um you don't see me saying
that the aliens created the pyramids but
it is interesting that they give credit
to others for everything they have all
the knowledge now people think that
that's of course symbolism for something
else
angels you know the gods so let's
discuss what the Sumerians said they
knew about that was later determined to
be correct
take the story of the Great Flood you
may be familiar with that from more than
500 different civilizations across five
continents around the world that science
the most recent data proves actually did
happen core ice samples taken from
Greenland and Antarctica and I've
discussed this in other videos they
illustrate that at the height of the
last ice age there are sea levels were
425 feet lower than today and over a few
thousand years it slowly rose but
there's these huge spikes that happened
that confirm that there were sudden
rapid and essentially incredible
increases in the global sea levels so in
other words the Sumerians were right the
flood did happen and it's interesting
that mainstream academics and scientists
still refer to it as a myth but what's
even more interesting than the denial is
the fact that the Sumerians knew about
this 6,000 years after the fact is when
they were writing this stuff down on the
tablet so it really makes you think now
look at this tablet here this is the one
this is very notable the infamous
solar-system tablet I mean just look at
this for yourself what do you see there
I mean how could they possibly have
known about planets rotating around the
Sun 6000 years ago I mean isn't that
more than 5,000 years before Copernicus
identified the planets rotated around
the Sun in just the same period of time
before even the first telescope was
invented when you need a telescope to
know that there was planets out there
and not to mention didn't everyone think
that the earth was flat back then how
did they know this stuff and so just to
clarify mainstream they will say that no
none of these are planets all of these
are stars and there's even a website
devoted to debunking zecharia sitchin
which is called get this Sitchin is
wrong comm and I took a look at this and
the point that this guy had was that
Sitchin didn't even read the kanae form
on the tablet itself and he describes
that he illustrates what it stated in
his PDF so I clicked on that and 14
pages basically discussed the fact that
since this tablet doesn't say anything
about stars or planets then yeah it's
just wrong altogether
I mean God just look at this and think
for yourself I mean what do you what is
that and this creates all kinds of other
speculation because it's like wait as
there are there 11 planets and so ok is
Pluto a planet like give me a break what
a stupid discussion that is some
scientists that want to redefine things
who cares how far away it is or how
small it is like grow up but this raises
other questions too about the asteroid
belt I've discussed this in other videos
it's clearly that was a planet or a
massive moon or something something
collided scientists will say it happened
millions of years ago but they clearly
don't have enough variables to make that
conclusion I mean you need to know the
size of these objects you need to know
the direction as well as speed of the
collision so they can't state how long
ago that was but when you look at these
tablets is it possible that this could
be communicating the so-called ninth
planet that they know exists all the
data proves that this ninth this massive
ninth planet four or five times the mass
of Earth itself was creating a tilt and
Neptune and Uranus and that's how they
discovered it well they haven't
discovered it they're looking for it
it's obviously incredibly far away and
my guess is that it probably has a
completely different orbit altogether
but they know it's out there and yet
here's this tablet from 6000 years ago
that shows these things and by the way
zecharia sitchin is the one that was
saying that there was another planet out
there and here was very years later
that's interesting but these tablets
contain other information as well take a
look at these tablets and there are
others that show
seven stars seven planets seven
something seven dots and many will say
that this is just probably indicative of
the platy star system seven stars but I
mean why isn't in the shape of it and
what's interesting is that people that
identify with the ancient astronaut
hypothesis is that look if you were
coming if you were coming from someplace
else
beings from another planet visiting our
solar system you would need to pass by
seven planets to get to earth it's an
interesting theory and by the way look
at this tablet that shows one of those
winged Bulls here's something else also
worth thinking about is that there's
suggestive evidence that the Sumerians
somehow knew about the great year cycle
the earth's tilt and precession 25,920
year cycle and when you considered their
awareness of the zodiac and a few other
factors with their counting system you
can make an argument that they somehow
knew about this cycle and I mean
thousands of years before the Mayans
figured that out and that's a mystery in
of itself too because we're talking one
degree every 72 years and back then the
lifespan was what half the age of what
is today so to figure that out is beyond
impressive and it's a mystery but to
wrap this up let's not forget they knew
about time the calendar they created all
these amazing things they knew about the
flood six or seven thousand years after
the fact they even knew and by the way
when going back to that religion comment
that I made at the beginning this video
the story of Moses from the Bible is
identical literally identical to king
sargon of akkad from 4000 years ago
right out of the same region so without
a doubt I think there's a religious
factor in preventing people from
learning about this information I mean
isn't that fascinating the story of
creation the flood
Moses and a few other things come right
out of ancient Sumer and nobody knows
about it they only teach us one two
three sentences in school and they don't
really teach that I mean I didn't know
about the Sumerians until watching
documentaries later on in life so we
have to start asking ourselves why are
these tablets being ignored and just to
paint you a picture out of these tens of
thousands of tablets most of which are
not on display and they're literally
gathering dust in the basements of
various museums throughout the world and
to make it even worse most of these
tablets were only interpreted once by
one person more than a hundred years ago
so these things need to be revisited
people need to look at them in this
discussion
open up that clearly they knew about
things they weren't supposed to know
about planets rotating around the Sun
without I mean five thousand years
before a telescope guys look at this
stuff think for yourself I'll wrap it up
here I'm Jimmy
this is bright insight like and
subscribe let me a comment let me know
what your thoughts are and I've many
other videos to come and a whole wide
variety of topics